[Music]
welcome to the week in 60 minutes
brought to you by spectator tv
recorded on thursday march the 11th on
this week's show
we'll be talking vaccine hesitancy not
from people of color
but from poles who live in britain we'll
also be taking a look at the murky and
the thrilling world
of commodities traders and how they're
never far from
exploiting a geopolitical crisis and of
course we'll be discussing
that interview you know the one i mean
so no need to spell
it out all that to come in the next hour
as always if you subscribe to the
spectators youtube channel
why wouldn't you it's free you'll never
miss a program
just click the subscribe button at the
bottom of the screen now
a very special thanks to charles stanley
for their continued support
of the week in 60 minutes charles
stanley is one of the uk's leading
wealth management firms
one of the oldest companies on the
london stock exchange
we're delighted to be partners with them
now the clearly publicity shy minor
royals the
duke and duchess of sussex opened up to
real royalty this week queen opera of
all the americas and beyond
only about another 100 million or so
around the globe got to watch and listen
to so the couple must have been pleased
that their wish for
privacy was being respected much of the
content was absurdly trivial
like tears over a floral dress but when
the interview touched on race and mental
health matters it was incendiary enough
to provoke an onslaught on the royal
family
from around the globe in this week's
spectator our deputy editor freddie gray
writes that harry and megan
have set up their rival royal house in
california
and he joins the show now together with
spectator columnist rod little
who muses on the american individualism
that explains so much of megan
marco well welcome to you both freddie
what do you mean by
a rival royal family across the pond
well i think harry and megan have
established themselves as a a house of
woke really and
i mean i think we tend to overuse the
word woke it's a bit of a sort of
catch-all
but it is quite useful in summing up
their worldview and their worldview
is very much oriented around celebrity
and sort of therapy really because if
you if you watch the oprah interview
it's like a long
counseling session um and this is
actually very potent in the media
because people love talking about their
feelings
and i think where harry and megan got
this idea from
was uh the heads together campaign which
was something the younger royals
launched
in 2017 when they decided that mental
health they wanted to do a big drive
on mental health and a lot of sort of
royal
people royal suckups pr operatives got
very excited
about this idea that the younger royals
could rebrand the monarchy by talking
about their feelings
and how much they suffered um but i
think other people within the royal
family realized this was quite a bad
idea and that people don't want
to hear uh royals gassing on about their
feelings
and so william and kate sort of pulled
back a bit from that i think
but harry and megan it came to them very
naturally and
and they couldn't stop themselves so
they they have become this sort of rival
house
of therapeutic woke culture and rod you
can see that in some of the language
that
both meghan markle and uh oprah winfrey
use because apparently what now matters
is that people have their own truth
what i think is truth is truth even if
it isn't true
yes and i i think i think it it lies at
the
at the very center of this this problem
we have with with megan and to degree
harry i mean
harry mattered so much less in a way
because the driving force
seems to be megan that it's
right from the beginning our antipathy
towards the woman
if there was any in the press and there
was
uh seemed to be not because she was a
mixed race
i don't know anyone who who objected to
the color of her skin
uh but because she was an american and a
particular kind of american who cleaves
to those values
which some americans do and you see that
in the narcissism
in the the relentless self-examination
and self-obsession
and i think it's the consequence i mean
i suppose it's a pretentious argument
but it's
it i think it evolves from america's
uh primacy of the individual over the
communitarian
in that you can if you're an individual
have your own truth
and you can if you're an indian
individual have your own concept of duty
which is what she said and her concept
of duty
didn't involve doing as she was told and
performing a service for a country
uh it involved scampering off to
california i.e doing what she likes
it's a very interesting view of the
world and i i think a lot of the
antipathy does come down to the fact
that it really is a culture crash
not not a not a racist culture just that
usual culture clash between uh the us
and britain and don't forget that that
individualism
uh we have imported to a huge degree
from america
uh and that individualism is is also
part of identity politics which of
course
both harry and megan cleave to again uh
that that people can be whatever they
wish to be
and that an individual what an
individual
feels is more important than what
actually the truth is
so i think an awful lot of that plays
into it it is interesting rod though the
way
the whole interview was framed and
particularly what megan marco
was saying with harry basically just
having a walk-on part
it's very much the way a lot of woke
dialogue goes there so if i feel
i've been victimized i am victimized
just enough to to feel it that
let's talk about me uh there's a
self-obsession here
but it's i'm the one that matters
particularly since i'm
a victim and i need to justify uh
myself that my truth matters more
than whatever the factual situation is
that i saw this
uh being used by the the weatherman on
good morning britain against pierce
morgan
it it may not be true but it's her lived
experiences this is
whatever this new phrase is and lived
experience if that's what you think it
is
trump's facts yeah what's an unlived
experience i've often wondered that
um i mean you're absolutely right and
and and
uh it shines through in everything she
says
but it's also clearly the problem that
there was with the royal family now
i agree with freddie i think most
americans don't give a monkeys about our
royal family i'm sure that's right
but it's that individualism i am now
part of this i think she thought
she was she was signing up to a kind of
rather gilded celebrity dom which was a
little bit like hollywood
where she could express herself and put
forward her very often inane beliefs
about the world uh uh with with
with no restraint and then as soon as
she found out that it was different to
that that there was something involving
service and discipline and dignity
involved
she scampered off to as i say to
california or canada as she
put it originally we we all knew they
weren't going to be staying in
moose jaw canada for very long and
indeed
they soon went to santa barbara so i
think that's exactly it
it is exactly that woke culture which we
have imported
largely from the usa and it devolves
always to the individual
and there is no communitarian sense
about it there's no sense about
about whether it's good for the royal
family or not or whether it's good for
great britain or not it's about whether
it's good for me
or not and that that's that's the great
difficulty and somehow
harry uh who it's a terrible thing to
say
may not necessarily be the brightest lad
in the world
uh has been kind of dragged along with
this and
i i still i still kind of uh
cleaved to the idea that maybe in a few
years time he will regret
what he's done uh but but uh certainly
doesn't seem to at the moment
it's still not clear to me freddie
whether she
[Music]
was properly briefed or it was properly
explained what being
a royal meant particularly one at that
time that would be
they were quite pretty senior royals
indeed it was meant to be uh
they were to be the beatles who were the
four it was will
and kate harry and megan that
was she properly briefed um
or wasn't she and even if she was
properly briefed did she just think i
can change this because
it does seem to me that she didn't
understand two things
being a royal is different from being a
celebrity uh
and you have to behave differently i
mean when when did will i see the queen
jump on a billionaire's
private jet uh it's just not
or be filmed in conspicuous consumption
it's just
not what they do plus you can't really
lecture people about global warming or
inequality or all
the rest of it that again is i mean
charles has got into trouble for
straying into some areas but it's really
not what you can do you cannot have
strong opinions
and you can't behave as if you are a
hollywood celebrity
and what i'm not sure is whether that
was spelled out to her
or whether she didn't realize it or it
was spelled out and she said
yeah but that's yesterday i can be a
celebrity hollywood style
and i can have opinions on whatever i
want silence remember she said
she was silenced what do you think well
i mean i'm not i found it a bit
disingenuous when she started talking
about
how you know she had no idea she didn't
really she hadn't even googled harry she
didn't really know
anything about this family that she was
marrying
i didn't quite believe that and i also
think that
it shouldn't really need to be spelled
out to you and i'm sure she
i'm sure she was told uh what the
protocol was on various things and then
she just decided
that that wasn't for her i thought it
was very interesting that both
megan and harry went to such lengths to
praise the queen
and i think that's because they they
don't understand much but they do
understand the power of brands and sort
of global brands
and in some sense they understand that
the reason the queen is so popular
is because she hasn't gassed on about
her feelings she's kept her mental
health
private and that's something they're
unable to do and what they can't
quite grasp is that they can't be royals
in the in the royal sense in the
traditional sense
and be these celebrities who gass on
about their feelings it's just not
sustainable for a monarchy in the
british sense
was there not though freddie something a
bit disingenuous you
you you praise the queen yeah we know
why they're doing that uh
whatever the view of the royal family
the queen's global image is uh
without parallel uh
better than ever i would say in in all
the years she's been on the throne
so you can hardly be seen to trash her
but actually you praise her
but you trash the institution which she
has been ahead of i mean it's
really is it not well i think that's it
i think they probably do
in some they probably can't admit harry
probably can't admit it to himself but
they probably do resent
the queen in some ways because they seem
to resent this institution that they
felt
trapped by uh i think as i say i think
the reason they praised her it was
disingenuous
was because they know that she's still
very popular and they don't want to mess
with her brand
while they establish their own one
well well rod
megan has got her way she is a celebrity
now they're a big celebrity i mean
she was a sort of seedless actress she's
now
if she called a dinner party in
montecito in california tonight
the whole a-list hollywood would go if
they're invited but she's more than just
a celebrity
she's now a cause celebra she's got
joe biden's press officer she's got
hillary clinton she's got
kia starma they're all piling in on her
side
where does it go from here well i would
hope into obscurity but it doesn't look
very much like that at the moment does
it
uh that's that's that's the great
problem
uh and it's something freddie was saying
and he was saying earlier about the
queen
that actually the reason the queen has
that reputation
is simply because she does the precise
opposite of what megan
and harry do that is why that brand is
strong
and the the question we're getting now
at the moment over here is what should
be done about the royal family
the royal family should try to adapt it
should we've
already got the queen dressed up as
agatha christie going around the various
members of the royal family to find out
who said the naughty thing about
archie's skin
and there's this feeling that we must
somehow modernize the royal family but
you can't
you can't you can't modernize it in the
way they want it to be modernized
it's an archaic institution we could do
away with it
perfectly reasonably i perfectly
reasonably see the argument for that
but what you cannot do is have a royal
family which is stripped of its reality
of its dignity and of its aloofness you
can't have that
freddie the queen uh clearly hopes that
this can now be resolved behind
closed doors she doesn't want to up the
ante with a public slang match either
from the royals or from those who work
for the royal family
which would only invite further
retaliation from
harry and uh and megan
can she do that because it's true this
is what strikes me
you can see why the royal family does
not want a public slagging match much as
they would like to reply
they can only have this resolved behind
closed doors if harry and megan agree
and of course they now seem to live off
the oxygen of
publicity this is what makes me think
that they might go along with this
take the most incendiary claim the the
the conversation apparently about the
potential color
of the baby if this is to be resolved in
public rather than behind closed doors
first of all harry and uh bacon will
have to get their stories straight they
didn't have this story straight
with oprah winfrey meghan markle began
by saying
it was she had me they had people had
talked to her about it
several times while she was pregnant
then when it got to harry it turned out
no they hadn't talked to her
it was him once before she was pregnant
and i didn't they would start to have to
name people give the context of it
give back up proper interview
investigation which of course
the queen of america did not give so
maybe they will have an interest there
freddie
in just getting this resolved behind
closed doors now they've had their say
well possibly and i mean uh the queen
and the royal family might
find some way to bring them back into
royal royal fault i i find that
unlikely i i think
i mean as for the allegations themselves
you know we might find out that
something was said in a relatively
innocent way that turned that then got
turned into something else we just don't
know uh and i find it again slightly
suspicious that they kept the claim so
vague um because if you do want to sort
of
set this ball rolling you need to be a
bit more specific about what you're
saying
yeah where do you think it goes through
from here
freddie i mean i had thought that once
they did the big interview
and they got things off their chest that
that was is going to be as good as it
gets for them
but i i'm not i don't think that's going
to be true
anymore this could be just the start i
think the i mean the royal families
had these sort of episodes before of
course there was diana but there was
also
fergie and i i watched an interview this
week while looking
trying to write my piece about and it
was fergie with oprah
uh and the amazing thing was how similar
the interview was if you take the racial
stuff
out uh it was pretty much the same
conversation and so
the royal family has to have these sort
of periodic
psychodramas to sustain interest
um but i i mean
the reason it always comes back it
always survives i suppose it's because
the queen has this
this brand and this sort of perceived
dignity um
my worry for the royal family and i'm
not that worried because i'm not that
much of a monarchist but
it is that once the queen dies you're
then left with
the younger generations who've done
nothing but psychodrama and and tabloid
style media for decades now and
can the monarchy still be dignified once
the queen's gone i'm not sure that it
can with the with the
the crop that's underneath okay i'll
just say i think andrew
i think you're absolutely right andrew
it's not going to stop and it's not
going to stop for a simple
mercantile reason which is that they
cannot afford to let it stop
that uh all of the deals which have been
struck
between megan and harry and netflix
and oprah and all of their podcasts
and their they're apparently also going
to be doing a situation comedy which
i thought they'd been doing anyway for
the last two years um
so so they're going to do all this stuff
and
all of that is predicated upon the fact
that he
is royal and she is royal and so they
have to be
simultaneously associated with the brand
even if it means knocking that brand all
the time it needs to
they need to keep their names in the in
the in the
in the limelight as being part of a
royal family so i think it will continue
for a long time until everyone gets
bored of it andrew i would guess
i think you may be right it means
freddie funny point of view that those
of us
who wish them no ill but but also have
really no interest in what they have to
say
think of what they have to say is of no
importance and they talk about many
things of which they have no
qualifications to talk
uh about and that it would be best if
they just faded into obscurity and then
they live a comfortable privileged life
and all the rest of it
that's fine we don't care about that but
we don't want to have to read them
uh all the time uh
we're not gonna get our way on that are
we ready
rod's right well it will come like
reality tell if they keep
their own productions if archwell their
creative production company
uh keeps going uh they'll become a
reality
tv program they'll become a a kind of
like a kardashian's crossed with made in
chelsea
uh and that is thrilling for some people
uh but most of us
will find it pretty boring and ghastly
and the ratings for these kind of
programs in the end
they may peak but in the end they're
always going to decline
they will yes season by season three
it's pretty boring
well uh while we've been on air we
we just see that prince william has
broken the
silence this is really quite surprising
almost it seems
as if he's gone against um what the
queen would wish
prince william is being reported by
chris ship of
itn we are not we are very much
not a racist family says prison prince
william
he broke the royal family silence on the
interview
to his brother harry says i haven't
spoken to him yet but i will do
that's just broken let's finish off by
getting your reaction to that
from both of you you first run uh
i suspect that of all the members of the
royal family who sat down to watch that
ludicrous non-interview uh i rather we
should have been you doing it andrew i
have to say but there we are
i think the the two people who
undoubtedly hurt the most
were william and kate uh
and i think my suspicion is that
i mean i know very little about the
royal family's internal workings but my
suspicion is that
that william and kate felt particularly
strongly
and were probably more inclined to say
something now
than any of the other members of the
family because most of those barbs
seem directed straight to kate and
william
and that's the story which the press has
had for the last
uh four or five years the question is to
how much it matters you know i saw an
opinion poll there was one in the daily
mail
and there was another opinion poll done
by yougov uh
i think in a way this turmoil which has
been caused
does not remotely reflect the views of
the people in the country
the vast majority of people in the
country have had enough
of harry and megan and rather like the
queen and that that
comes out in two opinion polls carried
out on the same day
i don't think it plays i don't think
they play at all well
in in in the united kingdom and perhaps
the royal family ought to be minded
not to say too much just to let them get
on with it because
by and large we're all with them ready
quick final word from you
well it's interesting with william isn't
it because although i'm sure it's very
difficult his falling out with his
brother and all that but
as far as sort of branding goes and and
william and kate are as interested in
branding as harry and megan in their way
uh they've been rather successful in
been presenting themselves as as the the
decent
uh dignified ones compared to the to the
wild
harry and megan i mean do you remember
when they did that
slightly ostensious uh or it seemed to
be ostentatious they flew ryanair and
had themselves photographed flying
ryanair
uh just a few days after harry and megan
uh had got in trouble for taking private
jets while boring on about climate
change
i i mean it is pr wars now and it's it's
pr wars between a younger generation
uh i think it's going to get very ugly
um and
i'm not sure it's very good for the the
institution of the monarchy
we're probably not gives us something to
write about though and talk about
no yeah we're not complaining freddie
thank you very much for that we're not
leaving the subject though we're
returning
to the politics of it because there are
politics involved in this
and it didn't take long for the royal
rift to turn into a political rift with
labor politicians in the uk democrats in
the united states
from joe biden down to hillary clinton
too expressing
their support for the duke and
particularly the duchess
and the government here being put in an
awkward position of not really
being able to say anything but more
right-wing commentators
are tending to be anti the duke and the
duchess
james forsyth is our political editor uh
katie bowles
is the deputy uh they both join us now
james
there is a political dimension uh to
this particularly when it comes i would
suggest to
britain's image and the rest of the
world
yes i mean the government are very keen
to stay out of this round boris jones
just wants to praise the queen
and sidestep the rest of it but as you
say andrew you know britain's
international reputation
has taken a terrible beating in the past
few days you know
i i think as you and i were disgusting
if you watched any of the us morning
shows the day after the interview
britain is being presented as some you
know backwards country with
you know all of these kind of prejudice
attitudes you know that you've got a the
the boss of a joke on the late night
shows uh
and i mean there is a question here
which is you know in terms of britain's
international reputation one of the
things that everybody knows about this
country
who knows anything about this country is
that it has a monarchy and
there's no doubt that harry and megan
for an international audience
have uh landed some quite serious blows
in that institution i think this is an
odd crisis in that it's not a
constitutional crisis in the way that
uh the charles and diana situation was
and could they be divorced or not be
divorced
uh because you know harry is sick in
line to the throne and he's and he's
only going to get further away
uh in that respect but uh i do think it
has
it has had an impact on the country's
international reputation
ktv the government is state student
that's probably wise
for the government to do that kiersar
though
has kind of showed sympathy for meghan
markle and seemed to accept a lot of
what he was said on the sheer politics
of it
is that wise this is a labor leader that
needs to bring
wind back the red wall i'm pretty sure
the
red wall will side more with the queen
than with someone who thinks she's a vic
someone of immense privilege
who thinks she's also a victim yes
initial polling i think is what is what
you would expect
in the sense that it's older voters who
are more supportive of the monarchy
and we don't have so much more of a
breakdown but it does seem to be that
divide between
young uh liberals some might use the
word woke
and then older voters and as you say it
really depends what kierstarm's priority
is
i think part of the reason kirsten made
the decision to
intervene to say these claims by meghan
markle must be confronted
and come across very sympathetic to her
to her
version of events what she what she said
her truth
um is because that she was going he was
going to face
and lots of figures in his party calling
on him to do just this
so i wonder if in a way it was partly
internal work
in the sense that there is a large part
of the party here have come out and
talked about you know
what they see as racist coverage in the
press you're already hearing work by
one labour mp who prince harry mentioned
in his interview
for writing a cross-party letter
offering support
back when the g conductor is asking for
full-time royals
about colonial undertones in the
coverage that labor mp
is now talking about bringing in new
press regulation the first letter
the one prince harry mentioned was
signed by many members of the shadow
cabinet
or women including annalise dodds so i
think in terms of
where the parliamentary party is where
the shadow cabinet is
i think they will be wanting to actually
take this position where they
are supportive to meghan markle and
perhaps looking at things like press
regulation
which i think makes some sense of why uh
kirsten chose to make that statement
james there is certainly one very
serious political implication here
the queen has spent most of her life
presiding over a hugely successful
transformation
from empire to commonwealth and she's
very proud of that
and the commonwealth is in terms of
numbers
uh overwhelmingly non-white it's a
multi-racial organization
with a non-white majority the queen is
the undisputed head
of the commonwealth but if you've got
megan
marco with prince harry's with harry's
support and agreement essentially saying
the royal family is racist that's a big
problem for prince charles
becoming head of the commonwealth yeah
and it's a particular problem because
the head of the commonwealth
is quite deliberately not a hereditary
position you know to distance itself
from that
but it has been i think a a big object
of british diplomacy over the last
decade or so
to try and ensure that prince charles
does succeed the queen as as head of a
commonwealth
and i think you're right this is i think
all of these debates about monarchy
uh in bristol and in in and the rest of
the commonwealth are essentially frozen
while the queen is on the throne she is
so respected
but what i think harry and megan have
done is they have provided
uh republicans with ammunition
for the moment that that will follow uh
in the succession you know people will
start to make the arguments about the
monarchy in an outdated institution i
think one of the great as you as you as
you as you said andrew one of the most
remarkable things is how the monarchy
has
has uh managed to dis manage to disa
the monarchy is no longer you know all
these debates about roads must fall and
imperialism colonialism
the monarchy has managed to to sidestep
votes and somehow be almost above those
debates
and i mean the danger is that the way in
which harry and megan are talking is
that they end up
dragging the royal family into those
questions
there's a generational factor at play
here katy too isn't there and
and also a domestic international factor
uh i think i'm right in saying the that
what megan markle had to say was a lot
more popular
popular with younger people than with
older people and that what she had to
say was a lot more popular
outside the united kingdom particularly
in america
than it was inside the united kingdom
yes and i think initial polling is
reflecting that the sense that younger
uh voters are much more sympathetic to
the uh meghan markle and prince harry's
accounts
and again that goes back to labour's
intervention you can see that i think
uh you could it's not a stretch to say
that i think uh
young labor voters are more supportive
of meghan markle
than older conservative voters and and i
think in terms of
how this plays on the world stage you've
had a situation where
boris johnson does not plan on saying
anything more than he has already
said but i think there is a question as
to how terrible it is
robert buckland uh one of the his
cabinet ministers criticized kirstama
for taking the position he did
but i do think that if we start to see
this having negative impacts not just in
terms of
whether prince charles becomes head of
the commonwealth one day but also you're
hearing reports of
various commonwealth countries unhappy
voicing concern
you have republicans um in australia
making
the case of really should we be
associated i wonder if boris johnson
will have to say something more because
it will start to affect
how the country is perceived and that
becomes a political matter
indeed how britain's reputation is
abroad
is a batter for the prime minister and
for for the government
katie james well i've got you here just
on some non
uh meghan markle uh uh matters
uh we're now looking at the government
on the defense of over a a one percent
pay rise
uh in the nhs what's happening
here katie the government must surely
have known
the the one percent uh offer was going
to create a huge row it's almost as bad
as no offer at all
um did it just get this wrong
or is it was it planning to be just an
opening offer
and of course the final settlement will
be more than that
well it's an interesting one because
when you scratch the surface it's not
quite a blame game amongst ministers but
the
everyone is very keen to say oh well you
know uh
this header department said that they
were pro fiscal restraint and actually
if you take into account
the wider economic landscape
there was agreement amongst ministers
including matt hancock
rishi sunak that actually to give a
much larger pay rise would be
disconnected to the reality in terms of
what the private sector are facing
looming mass unemployment potentially um
furlough has extended that slightly
um however i think that when you press
it does not seem to me as though this is
definite and everyone is very keen to
say well we're not going to get the
recommendation from the independent body
until
may so nothing has decided i had one
figure say to me this wouldn't be a
u-turn
if we if it wasn't one percent it went
up because it isn't actually the policy
yet
so you're already getting the sense that
people are beginning to realize that
this is a
politically difficult route potentially
and i think tory mps are worried that
it could end up being another free
school meals right which had the same
sense of bewiddleman which is why is
this the issue the government has
decided
to go to town on um given if you look at
this spending compared to other pieces
of spending and also how
politically salient it is and that's why
i think there are two workarounds that
um
mps the parliamentary party are putting
to the government
one being could you target um this pay
rise so
yes at one percent for some nh workers
but the lowest nhs workers would get a
higher pay rise
and two because you learn from the
devolved administration such as scotland
and
do the one percent pay rise but also do
a one-off pandemic bonus payment
to say thanks for your work and i think
those are those are things to look at
why uh if if it isn't going to be
resolved
to the summer why let it become
the settled view of the british people
that you're only going to get one
percent why let that
hang out there for so long if you
already known the end
it ain't going to be one percent um i
don't think they've yet decided it won't
be one percent but look
as as you touch on we've had boris
johnson come out there and defend the
one percent
you've had matt hancock defend the one
percent rishi st next defended it
i think so they are spending political
capital on it i just think there is this
creeping sense as we've seen with other
things they've spent political capital
on
such as free school meals that
eventually it'll be ground down and
labor clearly are very comfortable this
attack line
because stammer had one of his best
prime minister's questions this week but
i think as for why they're still pushing
it
i think that uh there is generally a
sense that they have to bring about
physical discipline in some way
and therefore the strong mastery message
has come from the treasury is
we need to show that if we spend money
on xx
then actually we have to raise money
elsewhere and we can't just spend so i
think that's underlining it
but there is this slightly weary sense
amongst mps that we are heading to a
deja vu
all right final question for you uh
james the uh
the salmon sturgeon rau continues to
rumble on uh nicholas sturgeon still
looks pretty well placed for the may
scottish parliamentary elections but the
um
the bloom is off is it not the shine is
off the polls
are big showing that it is beginning to
take its toll
yeah and we had a first poll this
morning suggesting that the snp would
not
win an outright majority at hollywood in
the
may elections we've also had in we had
20 odd polls with independence
uh in the lead you know the snp it
starts to make an argument that you know
this was becoming the settled will of
the scottish people nicolas sturgeon
used to kind of enthusiastically tweet
about these polls showing
the yes side ahead uh we've now had a uh
more than we now have a handful of polls
showing the union side ahead now
i think what is going on here is a
mixture of factors
one is uh the vaccine roll out that's
gonna
emphasize the benefits of of the union
but then i also think that you know
salmon sturgeon and this general air of
of sleaze that is beginning to emanate
around the snp
is i think beginning to do them damage
you know only 35 percent of voters
think that nicola sturgeon has been
entirely honest about this affair
and we know that 60 of voters think that
she should resign
if this investigation by james hamilton
which we are expecting
before the end of this month um says
that she broke the ministerial code in
our handling of all this
and indeed we've had the snp chief whip
in westminster
standing down resigning from that
position because of
allegations against him of a sexual
harassment nature too
we'll leave it there james and kenny
thank you very much
but we're not leaving the big story of
the week however
big story of the month in many ways
because of the most damaging part of
meghan markle's accusations concerned
race prompting questions
over whether the monarchy the media
british society as a whole
is more racist than it thinks were they
just the allocations of a victimized
snowflake or are we not as past
race and racism as much as we think
i'm joined now by dr remy adikoya
he's an associate lecturer in politics
at
the university of europe author of
biracial britain it's a different way
of looking at race remy
what did you make of
the duchess of sussex accusations
so first of all uh thanks for having me
and first of all i'd say there's uh
you know two levels of this there's the
small picture aspect and there's a big
picture aspect
so the small picture aspect regards who
said what specifically and how
and i agree that is definitely
interesting because we are talking about
the royal family here
but the big picture aspect for me is the
issue of colorism which actually is what
is at the background
of the claims meghan markle made so
essentially what she was saying
is there was you know worried that the
skin color of archie
might be slightly too dark for the
british royal family this
might be something which wouldn't look
good and this is a real problem colorism
is a real thing
um while writing my book i mean by
racial britain i spoke to people of
mixed race heritage so people like
archie essentially very often
and this is something which is discussed
in families and it is often discussed
in a context you know which implicitly
or explicitly
suggests that you know the lighter
skinned the mixed race a child is
you know the better that will be you
know the better looking that child will
be
and and and you know and these kinds of
and these kinds of things are real and
they don't only exist
unfortunately among white people also
within african societies unfortunately
there tends to be that sort of belief
that you know lighters can be you know
people buy bleaching screams you know
they tone their skin
society doesn't it sorry indian society
you said yes
exactly so you know so this is a real
thing so i prefer to sort of you know
for me
i see you know megan and harry you know
irrespective you know
what kind of personal opinions i might
have about them for me you know it's
useful when
individuals who do have an impact on
public discourse
race issues which are relevant and which
do affect millions of people so that is
how i approach this
well it's very interesting this issue
this colorism that you say
is interesting too and i'm slightly
puzzled in a way by
why anybody in the royal family would
think this was an issue i mean my
understanding
was of the certainty the sensible people
in the royal family
realized it was a huge asset that
someone of a mixed race heritage
had finally joined the royal family
because that would allow the royal
family to join the 21st century
and that to have at least one faith when
they appear in the balcony at our
national events or whatever
to have at least one face up there that
wasn't
pasty white like the rest of them was a
huge advantage and actually
given that meghan markle herself is
actually pretty light-skinned
it would help if the the kid
was a little bit more dark-skinned and
stand down a bit more you could argue
that actually
the problem is there's only one there
should be more than one one
yeah i get the point you are making let
me tell you how it looks from the
perspective
especially of dark-skinned black people
so from the perspective of dark-skinned
black people
they have this feeling and this is also
not just you know something people
invented in their minds
they have this feeling that when white
people
are ready to accept a kind of black
person
they want you to be as light-skinned as
possible a kind of black person
and so this is why and and this is a
complaint i've heard from many dark
skinned people this is why very often
you know on tv in the media
the kind of black people you will see on
your screens
will tend to be mixed race people or
people of a lighter skin color
and so they believe that the way the
royal family might have been thinking
and we're of course
operating in this field speculation here
and i accept that but like i said it's a
relevant subject
the way dark skinned people would
interpret this is aha
so what these people want is to be able
to have
a child that is you know technically not
white
slightly exotic looking but still as
white looking as possible
which they can present to the world and
then say oh look you know britain
where this diverse place and the royal
family is this diverse this is ever
something but they wouldn't like to have
a child that's darker skin that looks
more like us this is what the darker
skin people will think
that they wouldn't like that would be
too much that would be true black
you know and these are the kinds of
feelings that exist among people
and which you know created that kind of
reaction you talked about here how you
know the vast majority of the british
society
doesn't seem to have much sympathy for
um harry and megan and paul suggest that
clearly
however if we look at a breakdown of the
polls along
racial lines then the same poll the
daily mail poll
i think it was showed that 54 of ethnic
minorities
in britain agree with megan that she
suffered
racist abuse from the british press here
while 31
only of white britons agree with that so
there's a clear divide here and you know
and this comes down to interpretations
and perceptions remy when
dark-skinned people of color when they
make the
the points that you were just going
through there that that
white society is most comfortable
with with black people of lighter skin
or with asians from the subcontinent
with lighter skin
too um they're right are they not
i mean it is the lighter skins that have
made the most progress
so that's a great point you make andrew
and i think that's um very helpful
that you make that point that that point
m comes from you yes it is true
and you know if we actually if we study
identity so i've you know i've done
research on identity
and generally the way identity works
across cultures and across skin colors
is that you know people in their heads
have a sort of identity spectrum
now that spectrum starts from me and
then it starts from the
and then it ends at the opposite of me
and then there's people with positions
somewhere in between that
in between that spectrum of me and the
opposite of me
and so those we position closest to us
are those who seem more similar to us
and those we position furthest to us are
those who seem least similar to us
and so it is perhaps even not strange
that white people
will look at lighter-skinned people and
sort of instinctively
position us i see as a lighter skinned
person closer
to them than they would position darker
skinned people you know there's some
there's you know there's if we can call
them logical there's some logical you
know explanations to this with regards
to how human human
identity works so yes you are right you
know this is this is a fact
and this is an unfair fact an unfair
reality of course for the darker-skinned
people and so i get where they are
coming from
when they complain about this kind of
things and you know just to me just
sorry to interrupt you andrew just just
to further complicate this
and this discussion you know there were
discussions within the black community
and even you find them on twitter etc
so you know how black really is meghan
markle in the first place you know and
they're people who raise those issues
and say oh but come
on you know she's so light-skinned she's
never really experienced
real racism the kind of racism we have
experienced as darker-skinned people you
know so these kinds of discussions are
ongoing within the black community
which doesn't mean which doesn't mean
that if she's perceived as being under
attack
by the white establishment the troops
won't rally around her
in the sense of ah you know she's still
one of us
at this particular moment in time
are we then is because it's hard to know
what to do about this i mean are we in a
a process now i mean if you look back to
britain
of 30 40 years ago uh
on what was on television who our public
figures were it was what
99 percent white maybe more
maybe 99.5 uh white
um and we've made great strides in many
ways you look at television adverts
today
they're very multi-racial now uh our
football players some uh television
itself
presents still a long way to go nobody
denies that
but is it inevitable or can this be
telescoped in some way
that we begin by being most comfortable
with people of color who's
who are most like us and once we get
comfortable with that we'll get more
comfortable with people of
of color of all different hues is that
inevitable
or can we do something about it i think
something can be done about it and i
would um
to give you know credit where credit is
due i do think there's definitely
been an expansion of the
skin shades available in the public
realm here in britain
okay so there's more and more you can
see darker skinned actors and actresses
i see at least on my tv screens when
watching them
there's still not enough of them but
there's more and more of them
you know as the years as the years emma
progressed so i think there is a
realization
you know among at least some within the
industries that you know promote public
figures
okay within media et cetera there is
this realization you know
it's slow to come and of course you know
as human beings you know we're almost
you know
we're always more comfortable with the
people we're more comfortable with you
know that's um
that's um that's a reality but that
doesn't mean we don't
fight those instincts within ourselves
you know we need to one
acknowledge that look i have this kind
of bias
within myself even if i don't intend to
have it
it's there so you acknowledge it and
then say okay how do i fight this how do
i
consciously try to you know um transcend
this you know
as long as that acknowledgement is there
and there's a conscious effort to
transcend this you know that's how we
make progress as humanity
that's how we've always made progress
just finally regardless of of
who's to blame if anybody's to blame is
it
is it not a matter of great sadness that
it's come to this
here belatedly in the royal family a
person of color did join it
married a a prince a grand son of the
queen
uh the son of the next year to the
throne uh and although it was perhaps a
small step in the grand scheme of thing
it was a change
it was a difference it was what uh the
way it was
becoming representative of the kind of
society
britain is in the 21st century
and it's all lost it's ended in acrimony
and public dispute is that not a cause
for sadness
oh definitely it is because that wasn't
a small thing that was a big thing
because you know symbolic things are
hugely important i'm one of those people
you know
who cried the day obama was elected
president in america even because of the
symbolism yeah yeah
i was in america that night i've never
been
to america you know so so so these
things are important
and when she you know when she appeared
you see one thing which has always
pained um
black people is that because of you know
the history of you know slavery
colonialism etc a racial hierarchy
developed
and a racial higher that racial
hierarchy position white people are the
top black people at the bottom and
everyone else somewhere in between
one thing that is common to people
who've been assigned the bottom of a
racial hierarchy is the denial of
prestige
the denial of prestige and this is
something which pains a lot of black
people
and this is why when there's an
opportunity for prestige
and there's nothing more prestigious
than being a member of the royal family
in this country
and this is why that meant so much to so
many black people and they were happy
about it and proud about that oh we're
going to have a black princess
you know because that was overcoming
that denial of prestige
and then for it to you know end the way
it ended you know that's what's caused
so much frustration and anger
among so many people remy it's been a
pleasure to talk to you
thank you for being on spectator tv and
i hope you'll come back and
talk to us because these issues are not
going away
thank you very much now
we've talked a lot on the show about
vaccine hesitancy in minority groups
particularly among the the bam group the
ethnic minorities
and it's usually this hesitancy
associated with people of color
but the polish british journalist olenka
hamilton has written the spectator this
week about the reluctance
to take the vaccine within the polish
community in britain
uh it's a very good art interesting
article they are actually the second
most likely minority in britain to
refuse the vaccine
so why what explains it among pulse
we're joined by the author of that uh
article elenka hamilton
welcome to spectator tv explain
that now i think you say there are about
900 000 polls
living in the united kingdom a big
chunk of them are anti-vaxxers if i can
put it that way hesitant
uh about taking it why
um well there is a variety of things
going on here but i think
mostly it's that polish people have
never really well not you know in the
last 200 years not
really being ruled by benevolent
governments and
they just don't believe that we are
trying to do them good
basically it's very very difficult for a
polish person who's grown up under
communism
uh particularly and then you know under
under german occupation and many of them
are still alive today
to believe that that a government could
be could be trying to help them
and i think this is really deeply
ingrained in the polish psyche
and what really what really surprises me
actually is that
is that my generation of um of poles who
who didn't grow up under those systems
are just as skeptical of having the
vaccine it just
it shows actually how his like what what
a deep imprint history
can have on on a nation
well i'm very interested in this this
almost distrust of government because
for
over 200 years polls have had a very
good reason to distrust government
either because it was foreign oppression
or it was soviet communism which
combined uh
oppression with foreign oppression at
the same time i can see that
i was also interested though that you
said of british polls
of polls living either of polish
extraction or polls born there
but living now in the united kingdom
that they don't watch
much british media but they do watch a
lot of polish media
which contains quite a lot of the
anti-vaxx
uh memes and propaganda and
disinformation
um well it's not it's not mainstream
polish media
that is particularly spreading the
anti-vaxx
stuff it's um it's it's it's yes
it's the things that you read on the
internet which you know which which
could
you know i suppose you called fake news
um that's the sort of stuff that's going
round and this is relating
this is relating particularly to polls
um who have come over
more recently and who don't really speak
english
um and they do i mean they do live in
these sort of
a lot of them live in polish let's say
ghettos where um
they don't really mix with other people
and
um apart from people of polish origin
and um
and and so they don't so they don't hear
um they don't they don't hear english
language news and they don't hear the
opinions of anyone other than
each other and that's and that's the
problem two other
quick things your article which was an
excellent read it
it did surprise me that even
polish health workers i suspect not not
all of them i don't know
but a substantial chunk if i can put it
that way
of polish head health workers polish
people working
in the british health system are
suspicious of the vaccine
yeah so this what i lived in poland for
a few years
and i noticed that um there's a general
um
there's a there's a general sense that
that vaccines particularly
for fast mutating viruses like flu are
not necessary
unless you're very high risk so i think
what polish doctors have a problem with
is vaccinating an entire nation
um of people including healthy people so
i think that's the main argument
there i'd say and
because the question what is to be done
uh
we all feel that the more people that
are vaccinated the better
because that will help to make us all
safe and get through
this terrible thing which means
that we want as many of our uh
of the polls living among us to do that
too it probably does need the government
to think of an education campaign is it
not
uh yeah well there's already one going
on um there
various city councils um in areas that
have a high polish population
are holding sort of seminars and q and
a's
for polish people but i mean one thing i
would say is that i don't the polls
are naturally define nation because of
what they've been through but i don't
think they're intractable
i think that they are persuadable um and
you know i don't i don't think that yeah
i don't think we should
perhaps worry as much as my article
might have suggested
um well i hope you're right and that uh
that a majority uh do uh
see the need to get vaccinated but you
raise a very
important issue in the article thank you
for writing and thank you for being on
spectator tv
thank you for having me now finally
today
the world is built on commodities so
where did they come from
a new book takes a look at the traders
who go into war zones
corrupt regimes they buy and sell oil
rare earths
grains all sorts of things oftentimes
they
even shape the geopolitics in the region
some of the stories could be straight
out of
john le carre the difference is they're
true
and they reported in a book uh called
the world for sale
is by two bloomberg journalists javier
blass
and jack farshi and javier joins me
now thank you for joining spectator tv
rogue traders uh it's a fascinating talk
that you tell here but you say that the
commodity traders
can even be the heart of geopolitical
crisis
the arab spring uh the collapse of the
soviet union
anti-western coups are they really that
powerful
they are looking for business in places
that they need commodities and what
happened
is that in most of those places uh they
because of the way that they seek the
business they have a political impact if
you look at
uh for example cuba with fidel castro he
was short
of oil and needed to sell his sugar and
he could not find a way to do it without
the help
of the commodity traders so they were
very important for sustaining the cuban
revolution
or in the case of libya in 2011 the
rebels
rose in arms against muammar gaddafi
seeking freedom for 42 years of
dictatorship
but they were short of gasoline it was a
bit ironic in libya an oil producer but
the refineries in the rebel area they
didn't have any access to oil so they
needed someone to supply the oil
and the company that came to the rescue
of the rebels was beetle
an oil trader base in in london who
supplied the rebels
not only with the gasoline they extended
a credit line
of a billion dollars to the rebels with
at that point
they didn't have cash or a central bank
or any prospect of a government
so that's when at the way that they seek
business may have a political impact
because commodities and power go
together in many countries
it sounds that although they may be
huge capitalists and they they may be
playing the market economy
that they'll they'll work for anybody oh
absolutely marriage which was
in a way the godfather of the commodity
traders worked for
um pinochet and worked for uh fidel
castro and did business with both of
them
almost simultaneously they they they are
a political they don't care about
a right wing or a left-wing government
they are used for the money
and they are very happy to to to help
anyone that needs to sell or buy the
commodity
and i was in c2 in the book that i mean
bribes have always played a big role in
in this given the kind of governments or
people that you're
dealing with but at one stage i think
until recently that they
if if the traders were based in
switzerland i think mark rich was based
in switzerland for an example
uh there that the bribes were tax
deductible
uh andrew you are absolutely right and
not only they were tax deductible
they were tax deductible until about
yesterday uh switzerland
didn't ban the the tax deductible of the
as they call it commissions because they
were not calling that bribe
they call it that commission uh it
didn't stop that happening until 2016.
and we were researching the book i was
so taken aback by that
fact that uh we we kind of double check
and triple check and
are we really sure that you could put
against your taxes in 2016. uh
it was it was an astonishing realization
but yes i mean we
we quote a trader of the company that
became
uh later the company was funded by mad
rich but later became glencore and he
told us
how very often he came to london
heathrow
with half a million pound in cash in his
suitcase
to pay some um you know commissions and
and then he said but you know they were
legal and obviously
they were tax deductible at the point so
he was coming in with a
suitcase full of cash even though when i
come into the country i see signs saying
if you've got more than
i think it's ten thousand pounds uh it's
not that you can't bring in more than
ten thousand
but you have to declare you have to tell
the authorities look i'm bringing in
twenty thousand not ten and they may say
well that's fine or
well right but where did you get the
money kind of thing but he just went in
and out with
a lot more than that yes and and he was
coming so
you know so often to heathrow with that
kind of money that at some point
he got stopped by custom officials in
heathrow airport
and obviously they they asked well what
do you need this money for on and
and obviously they they will ask him for
a receipt on the way back
what you did with the money because as
you say andrew you
you come or i come to to heathrow with
that kind of money i'm gonna i'm gonna
face some questions
so obviously he was not gonna get a
receipt for the use that he was gonna
give to the money
so he told the costume official i go
gambling
and then he said you know he said that i
lost the money
and they bought that apparently so yes
we we talked to him
he's a free man in switzerland well i
must remember that
the only problem is i don't gamble but
i'll remember nevertheless
uh you give that you mentioned glencore
there there's a fascinating
very uh contemporary now that so the
pandemic pandemic is beginning
to spread which will inevitably have a a
downward effect on the price of oil
glencore does two things it it first of
all
buys up all the storage space it can
find including
tankers floating in the sea and then
when oil gets
really down it goes in and buys up that
oil
and stores it and then at a profit i
think you said of over a billion dollars
1.3 billion
it then as the price rises again it
sells that oil
now i looked at that and i thought
it's quite clever in a way i'm sure they
do that
all the time but what was there anything
wrong with that or is that just
oiling the wheels of global commerce
the traders are very important for
global commerce and actually we do need
them we need the traders to play this
business function of linking the
producers and the suppliers
and for that they should be rewarded
because they are risking their capital
and
and they are they are providing a
service to the global economy but yes
they were very clever they saw earlier
than everyone else
that the oil demand was about to
collapse because of the pandemic
we were starting to go into lockdown so
they they bought the oil
they store it and they sold it six
months later making a big profit
in many ways you could argue that that
was a good thing
because if no one has stored that oil
the
oil industry will have suffered more uh
they will have to shut down more oil
fields
lay off more people and probably now we
will have a problem that
there was not enough oil to go around so
for that service they held the oil
industry probably they held the global
economy
but obviously they held themselves very
nicely with more than a billion dollars
in profits
they certainly did uh are the glory days
of the kind of traders you write about
are they over
or are they always going to be with us
we're going to need
commodity traders for as long as we need
natural resources at the end of the day
i have a coffee this morning uh probably
was coming from central america and i'm
not gonna be the one who is gonna be
collecting
those coffee beans in a port in costa
rica and bringing it here
home into the united kingdom so we will
need then but the glory days
of everything is possible you could deal
with any government that you want
and often you are coming to heathrow
with half a million pounds in cash
to to bribe someone that's that's over
uh we have authorities the uk serious
fraud office
the u.s department of justice
investigating now some of the big
traders and also the world has changed
in the past
a trader will have better information
about the market than anyone else
today that information is more
democratic and
and the internet has spread i i find
fascinating
on my traveling covering the natural
resources industry
going somewhere in say ivory coast
and go to a a small village and someone
has a smartphone
and with that smartphone they know the
price of cocoa in the london market
on that day 20 years ago that was not
possible so one of the advantages of the
traders
which was access to information that is
being eroded but we are going to need
the traders and they are going to still
be around for our for for years
probably decades well it's a fascinating
book it's well reviewed in the spectator
this week uh i think you've got it
strategically you're clearly a book
trader
you've got it strategically placed
behind you which is very good
people can see it it's called the world
for sale it's a great read
it's about very important topics uh and
it's well worth your time
javier blass thank you for joining us on
the spectator tv
good luck with the book uh too and
that's it for this week thanks all of
our guests
once again to our very special sponsor
charles stanley the sponsor of the week
in 60 minutes
uh charles sunny one of the uk's leading
wealth management firms
one of the oldest firms on the london
stock exchange
as always please send us any thoughts
you have on spectator tv
to spectator tv at spectator dot co
dot uk that's it for this week
we'll be back next week bye bye
[Music]
you